le black friday aux etats unis c'est la
frénésie vers les bas prix
on a une télé les abstenons nous de
juger nos voisins d'outre-atlantique
car même si le black friday n'a pas la
même ampleur en france
ici non plus on ne rigole pas avec les
bonnes affaires
machine à laver vélo vêtements en tout
genre les prix cassés attirent qui t'a
poussé à la surconsommation qui font
tourner les têtes et ça ne date pas
d'hier années 60 les trente glorieuses
la france devient société de
consommation à l'heure des grandes
surfaces et du renouvellement incessant
des produits l'achat sans besoin
préalable compulsif est guidé par les
ficelles du marketing déjà en 1965
ce modèle est dénoncée par georges perec
dans son livre les choses la publicité
des étalages les vitrines une certaine
manière nous rendent fous nous saoulent
toutes ces choses de son acte pour
entretenir une espèce de frénésie de
vertige hypnose en même temps la
consommation est une arme de relance
économique
celle que brandissait par exemple
georges pompidou en 1970 lors d'une
conférence de presse je demande aux
ménagères française et je le redis c'est
le moment pour vous d'acheter les
machines à laver
c'est aussi et l'épanouissement
personnel dans tout ça l'électroménager
la voiture la télévision tout cet
équipement est brandie comme
émancipateur tout le monde s'équipent
dans une société qui avance
mais ce modèle a
limite c'est ce truc explique françois
de closets en 1974 dans son ouvrage le
bonheur en plus je crois que de
poursuivre le bonheur à travers
l'augmentation du confort et les miens
matériel c'est une voie il lit choir
c'est une voix illusoire et qui nous
conduit maintenant à des crises de plus
en plus graves
la surconsommation et son impact sur la
société sont des objets de critiques
depuis les années 60 avec le temps les
incitations à l'achat se sont
multipliées avec les centres commerciaux
plus le commerce en ligne contre ces
phénomènes
il ya aussi ceux qui résistent amateurs
de l'achat de seconde main ou d'une
consommation raisonnée
[Musique]